you're watching who wants to be in the
San Fran PD
well apparently no one in California so
San Francisco PD is turning to the Lone
Star State the department has been
holding job fairs at four Texas
universities to persuade young people to
join their force and it's been a success
for the job recruiters so far as they've
decided to stay in Texas
ha ha ha
who are the right mind in Texas Emily
would actually accept a job in San
Francisco where they actually hate the
police that's what I'm saying what
happened to all the defund the police
chants take those same picket signs you
held that said deep on the police take a
little Sharpie cross out the D put an r
and then you got refund the police to
undo the stupidity that you created
congratulations guys yeah
you played yourself
shooting tires be sending social workers
instead of the police because remember
that that was the social workers went
out yeah still looking for them yeah
it's true the social workers never came
back so dog catchers you're up yeah
to bring your ass to Texas to try to
convince young men and women of the Lone
Star State to go get this go up and get
a job that you're going to get canceled
from yeah ruined from and probably put
in jail yeah doing your job there's not
a chance in hell this is going to happen
this is what and they can't refund the
police anymore because it's not about
money for police officers anymore it's
about
spitting in their face
treating them like they're the criminal
going after them they want to take away
qualified immunity not to the
politicians who can say and whatever
they want but police officers are in the
line of fire there is no you cannot
encourage one the I if they get one
person I would be very worried about it
it'd be because no one in their right
mind would go into any of these states
that don't support the police department
and even if you do make an arrest you're
going to be arresting the same guy 20
times because your da is going to let
him go because handcuffs are racist so
you know what I'm saying so I mean
there's just no absolutely no nothing
nothing it would take it would take an
entire change of the administration
you'd have to have to have new DA's
you'd have to have new support and then
they're not going to do that Todd I'm
going to ask you you look like uh uh
timeshare salesman let's be honest I am
I don't even know it's kind of an insult
but let's go with it
so San Fran has this homeless problem
they got drugs they got crime they're
down 600 officer what officers what
would be the sales pitch that would get
someone to join the force you're you're
making the sales pitch well I thought
long and hard about that and I think to
a certain extent it's to what Tyra said
what is the number you know the
expression we all have our number what
is that number that dollar amount that
will get a Texas a million dollars well
I don't know what that number is to
leave the safe confines of Texas whereas
a police officer you're probably lauded
in 85 percent of the state and you don't
have to pay a state income tax to the
fecal line Streets of San Francisco
where you also do have to pay state
income tax eco line eco line good that
was beautiful but then I thought a
little bit more about and I said the
person who's going to take this job has
to have that same mentality as somebody
who enters the military somebody who
knows they're going to be leaving our
country for a foreign country which
ultimately is what San Francisco has
become going to be going into a third
world situation and going to be trying
to restore the ideals of American
democracy to that individual all in the
ideals of American Freedom so you have
to have that military mindset literally
to go to become a freaking cop in San
Francisco and think about how ridiculous
that is but that's the only mindset of a
person that I think is going to want to
do that job it has to be a completely
selfless person who wants to restore our
cities to their once great great uh you
know greatness you so you're basically
talking about kill Mead yes he has
restored Masterpiece I would like him to
leave and go to California to be a
police officer Loftus you're well known
by the police and the local and the
local libraries where you sleep is this
a wise decision to leave the Splendor of
Texas for the Streets of San pupisco
yeah
[Music]
yes
pooperoni treats
I don't I I think this is all kind of
offensive in a weird way it's kind of
stereotypical you know like San
Francisco's like where can we find the
toughest most rootinous tootinist you
know right we have a lot of on the
ground we need people to wear kickers
right why did why didn't they go to
Pennsylvania to recruit why aren't they
why aren't they in Connecticut you know
because everybody in Connecticut looks
like me
[Laughter]
even the black people do right it is
weird I've seen it
it is funny it's like almost like you
know what they're you it's amazing you
stumbled onto a good point
out rare uh it's like California is like
we need we need to hire our help outside
yes because we you know we don't we
don't like to do it we're you know we're
upper class you know we like we like the
Finer Things but we don't we let's get
let's Outsource where can we get some
dumb tough Hicks yeah exactly let's go
to let's go to Texas by golly we don't
we probably don't even have to pay them
very much no they probably yeah it's
gonna be impressed yeah exactly what
money I get money for this
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else